george kelly claimed that people were
natural scientists you know
that we're always investigating
hypothesis and trying to disprove them
and so on and it's an interesting theory
and
it's right in a sense but fundamentally
it's wrong we are not natural scientists
we're natural engineers and when we look
at the world
we don't see objects and then in further
use what we actually see
is the use so for example when i look at
that coke can
my my visual system activates my motor
cortex
directly it can do that without me
seeing the damn can consciously
to some degree because there are people
with blind side i've told you about
those people
they say they can't see but if you ask
them which hand you have held up
they can tell you so they might not be
able to
see but they can map patterns from their
visual system onto their motor output
you know and that's basically what
piaget said we do when we
deal with the world we're embodied
creatures you know and so what we see
when we look around aren't
objects there are things we can use and
things that get in our way
you know and that's a theory that was
derived originally from jj gibson
who wrote a great book on that called
the visual approach to ecological
ecological approach to visual perception
and his
science is a brand of pragmatism and the
pragmatists basically claim that
you know things including theories and
perceptions have a limited range of
truth and the truth that that
the limited range of truth is determined
by the match between
your actions and the outcome so i think
this is a coke can
is that what it is no but it's good
enough for me if i want to drink a bit
of coke out of it
god only knows what it is you know if
you go into communist china
and you start advertising these things
then what are they because this thing
tells a story
right what's the story like really do
you need coca-cola
no it's like it's a bit of frippery you
know it's a bit of it's an unnecessary
luxury
it's not even very good for you but it's
kind of fuzzy and it's sweet and
you get to buy it and why is that
because no matter how stupid you are
in your nutrition choices as far as our
society goes
you have the right to poison yourself in
whatever way you think
best befits you and so when you send
this little coke can
off to communist china this thing
screams stupid individuality all over
and god only knows how it undermines the
state you know and if you don't
if you're not thinking about that you're
not thinking think about what happens
when we export
cars what does a car say
it says hey you can go wherever you want
whenever you want you don't have to tell
anybody at all
and you can do it in a really dangerous
high-speed manner
it's like you want a political statement
wrap it up in metal and ship that thing
off and everybody
goes whoa i'd really like to have one of
those it's like poof
communism disappears with that you know
the
there's nothing that says individuality
and capitalism like a
personal automobile you know you even
get to pollute the atmosphere and ruin
the planet with the damn thing but
you know if you have to drive to the
corner store and pick up your damn coke
it's like to hell with the atmosphere
so don't be thinking that the things
that appear in front of you are merely
objects because they're not
you know i started thinking about this
for example when i was thinking about
people going down to graceland to look
at elvis's guitar
you think what exactly
is it that makes a guitar elvis's guitar
you know it's not exactly the guitar
because it's just sitting there like any
old guitar you know and maybe you could
even think about it you could take that
guitar out
and you could put another guitar in that
looked just like it and it would still
be elvis guitar because no one would
know
and you might think well then that's not
really elvis's guitar
but that's a funny thing because you'd
only think that if you thought that
elvis guitar was the thing that was made
out of material that was sitting right
in front of you
and that isn't what it is that's only
one tiny little bit of it
that bloody thing is is a part of an
incredibly layered reality right
i mean the people who want to go look at
that
they're looking at it in some sense
because of the magic that's emanating
from it but the magic is actually real
you know the magic is the effect of that
guitar
let's say on the entire culture and
those effects are the damn guitar too
and it's weird because when you go look
at elvis guitar you're not looking at
the guitar
you're looking at the magic and weirdly
enough the magic is actually real
well you can't think that way if you're
a materialist because you think that the
thing is the material it's like
yeah right i can tell you another story
so
when the um when the europeans came to
the south pacific islands
the south pacific islanders because
there weren't that many of them they
didn't have a very
high highly technical society you know
and so like if you were like joe
dominant guy in a pacific island culture
you know you might be able to have a
stone axe like a well-made stone axe
because you go out and make a stone axe
and see how long that takes you it's
like
that's a bit of work and so if you're a
high status guy if you've really worked
your whole life to be at the top of your
damn pyramid you get
maybe you get had two axes you know it's
like a red letter day
you've got two axes you know which is
more than any other animal has
by a lot so it's not trivial and then
the damn missionaries come in they
and they set up shop and what do they
bring
steel axes it's like that's kind of a
downer
you know you've worked your whole damn
life to get these stone axes and that
makes you like head
tribesmen and then you want your kid
wanders down to the local missionaries
and they say
oh we got an extra steel axe here why
don't you take that back home
and it's like it's so shocking because
not only do the missionaries have this
thing that is so much better than a
steel axe it's like a jet plane
compared to a to a wheeled cart
like they're really really different but
the missionaries
they don't even notice that's the
horrible thing about it it's like they
give away this thing that has a
virtually infinite value and it's like
well it's okay we got you know a couple
dozen of those sitting in the store room
and
you know we're just willing to hand them
out it was a little demoralizing
it was a little demoralizing for the
pacific islanders
and so you know what was it an axe that
the missionaries gave away
it wasn't you'd think that if you were a
westerner and you had a bunch of axes
it's like yeah that's an axe it's like
yeah right
it's a lot more than an axe a lot more
it's a weapon to bring down a whole
culture accidentally